[Music]
hello good morning
wired crossed with design crossed with
Skywalker's out-of-this-world we're
thrilled to be here so let's take a
journey from Earth to Mars if you allow
us imagine all the world leaders in the
united nations looking out the window
and seeing spaceship earth coined by
Buckminster Fuller the Renaissance
engineer designer architect he had the
pleasure to have him as an advisor for
his lunar base colony
Bucky's vision was that we make
different decisions important decisions
if we saw the world the earth as our own
blue dot our own spaceship and if we
could see war famine hunger and
celebration and music that we would see
it very holistically we would see earth
in its entirety this morning was a
beautiful sunrise but maybe not as
beautiful as Earth rise from moon I'm a
rocket scientist an engineer and I have
the great job to work with great
students and our goal is simply to
design the world's best spacesuit so we
can get people to Mars it's been a great
collaboration that I'd like to tell you
about have to understand the current
spacesuit it's fantastic it's an
engineering marvel it keeps you alive
gives you acciden scrubs out your carbon
dioxide gives you the pressure that you
need to survive in the vacuum of space
beautiful wonderful but it's kind of big
and bulky and heavy so we have some
great design challenges just waiting for
us we've been working on them for a
couple decades 45 years ago the Apollo
suit again a phenomenal engineering feat
but couldnt get a lot of science done
1/6 gravity of the moon so you really
light you low but just can't reach down
there to get my scientific pack we'd
like a little bit better locomotion this
bunny hop um you know we'd like to give
you a natural motion so a little hard to
get our exploring done again great for
45 years ago but we can do better that's
our challenge the current suit today
this is astronaut Cady Coleman going for
a training run underwater in NASA's
neutral buoyancy lab
the world's largest swimming pool at 6.2
million gallons so you dress up it's a
hundred and forty kilos that's close to
300 pounds gas pressurized and you're
really fighting and you have to move to
move the suit so you're wasting probably
75% of your oxygen just to move this
suit we're gonna introduce you to three
different design concepts so three suits
first the gravity loading countermeasure
suit kind of called the blue suit so
one-handed push-ups are great when
you're really in a microgravity
environment we're flying on the NASA
plane this is a compression garment so
it's loading from the shoulders down to
your feet compressing yuri compressing
you because you actually grow a couple
centimeters when you get into the
weightless environment you have a lot of
muscle loss 30% muscle atrophy that's
the good news the bad news is the bones
1 to 2 percent bone mineral density loss
per month now who wants to go six months
on station we have a one-year mission
coming up so our designs for these
compression garments or this is an
exercise countermeasure inside the
vehicle but to really help the
astronauts stay healthy and well as well
as and you have to do this in parallel
with exercise you know rowing and on a
treadmill to the left you see a little
fella we're using our same design
technologies the materials and the
design for little folks with motor
control disease right here on earth
this little fellow has cerebral palsy
can we help his daily activities just
just help him step help him walk help
his motor control just be a little bit
better so he can enjoy just daily
activities of being a fun little
six-year-old we're working on it we
still have a way to go second suit I
want to tell you about a suit within a
suit if you will so developed and design
the technology for the current systems
for the current gas pressurized suits
again they're fantastic but they're so
big they're oversized and there's a lot
of injuries matter of fact we have from
the shuttle and station astronauts 25
shoulder surgeries injuries from
training going underwater doing all of
it training 12 hours of training for one
hour of spaceflight so what was the
design innovation how could we help well
maybe we could map maybe we could map
the human motion where are those
injuries potentially going to take place
and then could we do something about
solving it so we've come up with a with
a suit within a suit that I'll show you
part of pop the octopus I'm wearing it
and we developed these pressure sensors
so that we can get that that map if you
will so these are red sensors all over
these little sensors here see why we
call it the octopus it straps on so as I
move and as I make contact with the suit
then these pressure sensors are giving
me that map and they're showing me how
what the force is how do we do it well
these are actually microfluidic channels
you push on them get very
high-resolution pressure sensing and
over the whole body it's a collaboration
with Rob woods lab at Harvard University
it's a great MIT and Harvard
collaboration how does it work
so we did strap it on the subjects put
them in the NASA Mark three suit this is
down at Johnson Space Center in Houston
and let's take it for a roll trying to
get maximum ability to trying to measure
in how I'm moving and then how I'm going
about moving the suit and how much
energy is all that taking me maybe like
I said maybe I'm wasting a lot of energy
just trying to move the suit you see
some sensors on the outside of the suit
because we're also measuring the outside
motion better than the Apollo suits mm
but we still have a long way to go oh
the students love that they call that
the reverse Macarena
so it's wired you guys no one's afraid
of the data here so so this is from six
different sensors and what you're
showing that showing is as I make
contact with these different points then
it goes along so we can see here's maybe
where injury is this is what the force
is so we can really quantify now for the
first time it's kind of our eyes inside
the suit so real high point here on the
forum underneath the arm because I have
to move the arm of the suit up
now I reach across and so there's a
point right here of pressure move over
here so again just kind of really
looking at the detailed and this map and
what the pressure levels are and will
they cause injury or not and then the
final phase of this design is actually
how can we do something about it
this is actually a collaboration with G
this is their latest prototype key
working with dye nazy and industrials
under me how crass is from Poland so how
can we
actually protect it's an active system
it's kind of like airbag technology but
you're wearing it and protecting your
shoulders it still gives you all the
mobility you need but it's really
wonderful three-dimensional materials
that again it sizes I need about four
centimeters to take up the room in this
suit but someone else might just need
one MIT one millimeter so it's all very
custom fit and we're hoping that this
can dissipate the energy and we'll be
testing this in the the NASA suit coming
up in early 2015
moving on to the third suit the bio suit
which you see here we've have a mock-up
to show you and I'd like to tell you a
little bit about that design-wise
without you know clean sheet design all
these gas pressurized suits is all that
we've ever done it's all that we've ever
known for NASA and the Russian program
everyone has been in a gas pressurized
you know 140 close to 300 pounds suit
for microgravity it just won't cut it
when we get to Mars why Mars it's
challenging it's pretty far away but it
does make sense in the future send
humans and Rovers to Mars we have five
current missions to Mars right now the
Rovers are vehicles three of them are on
the surface getting us a whole bunch of
scientific data on Mars
we just landed last week in the oil in
orbit of Mars maven from NASA and the
Indian Space Agency is now orbiting Mars
too so we know a lot about Mars the
radiation and the environment and how to
work on Mars and it is challenging
Olympus Mons is right here in the middle
second highest volcanic volcano known in
the solar system three times Mount
Everest so for all you climbers out
there there's still more challenges in
the solar system and Valles Marineris
the Grand Valley of Mars Grand Canyon
not Valles Marineris is ten times the
length of the Grand Canyon so we have
some extreme exploration to do how do we
think we're gonna do it well the biosuit
then says we're not gonna go with the
gas pressurized system we still need to
pressurize you it's the pressure layer
so it's mechanical counter pressure I'm
gonna squeeze you it is literally a
second skin suit so we're gonna put the
pressure directly on your skin we have
to create a third of an atmosphere so
we'll create a third of an atmosphere
and then how do we do that we actually
do that through both the material
properties and the design if I'm really
interested in how do I get maximum
flexibility how I'm gonna rappel up this
mountain
olympus mons how can i have maximum
flexibility and not be restricted well
we look at the body we study the body
and matter of fact we for an aerospace
engineer and a way too much about the
skin so as you're moving if you drew
little circles all over your skin and
moved around lots of those little
circles would turn elliptical like the
animation playing so there's two red
lines those bisecting diameters from the
circle to the ellipse they pivot but
they do not extend they're very special
little bisecting diameters if I connect
all those red dots it's really just the
mathematics we actually get this suit so
the black lines here on this suit so if
we do that again we're looking at the
basis of kind of a second skin and it's
a kind of a soft exoskeleton we can do
that I can have enough structure of the
suit but I can get you maximum mobility
so that's the patterning and then the
materials were always looking for
advanced materials as well to give us
the pressure production so we've hit our
targets just recently with some using
some shape memory alloys some active
materials in concert with the design and
the patterning and then lately we've
also have a brand new helmet to
introduce you to so introducing G my
partner and in soul mate tell you about
the new bio suit helmet guys
is wonderful to work with this lady
lured area and the latest part of the
biosuit is working on this helmet we're
spending a lot of time trying to make it
lighter I mean David is the leader
designer constantly make it lighter and
thinner so this suit eventually probably
be a thicker skin the idea is to make
this helmet you know as mobile and
visible as possible it changes the
changes are great compared to what the
NASA present suit is and this one you
move your head with it you know we
increase the visibility because we want
to do exploration or you want to work
with your hands we still have visors to
to add as you see in the image we have a
bar where actually we all attach tools
such as videos equipment scientific
equipment and so on
so I've been working on this thing for
about 35 years and the space business
since I was a student I became injected
by the virus of space and as an
architect and designer basically has
veered my life totally to another world
where I thought I was going and this
started in literally in 1969 arriving in
Houston a few weeks before the Apollo
landed on the moon and since then I and
as an architect I wanted to work in
space I was down the street I went to
NASA and eventually got involved in the
lunar bases and and many of the designs
that you see up here we were working at
the time and glorious projects of very
large space stations where we would had
colonies and low Earth orbit colonies on
the moon it's taken a long time but
today we have an incredible laboratory
in space this is our space station this
is a place where astronauts work every
day of the year we have six to nine
astronauts constantly there
experimenting living learning this thing
is about over a hundred yards long is
longer than a
full-field so I had the privilege of
spending about 10 years working in the
interior of this Hardware looking at
really the human factors how humans will
live here how humans will eat sleep and
all of the habitation aspects or with
the other human factors I mean you're
designing for an environment that you
don't know anything about so we've spent
a lot of time flying in this NASA plane
the vomit comet as we call it so and
then a lot of time underwater so we
spend in the neutral buoyancy this is a
galley the space station is designed
with these modules so we have about 300
1/2 of these modules to pack food to
store it to freeze it to refrigerate it
to prepare it so we went all the way
from the design of the packaging how do
you actually store these things and in
space you know you don't have
particulars without zero gravity
we're in zero gravity without gravity
you don't have convection so really
creating an oven the oven was a
beautiful design to make it work at the
beginning of really injection heating
and and so on so we spend tremendous
amount of time really working and
full-scale prototypes actually building
these things and testing them with
astronauts and the other part that I'll
show you today is the sleeping quarters
where we spend time designing the
sleeping bag for that restraint you and
holds you you know we talk a lot with
astronauts about how they would like to
sleep and some of them just float around
and they sleep right here and wake up
over there over the roof and you can
travel you know because the air pushes
for you around so and skylight with the
first space station people would sleep
this way because there was only three
now it would be difficult with all this
too much too many guys hanging around so
we worked on this on the space creating
the most private space you know we took
care of acoustics lighting communication
safety so this is your personal space so
what is next
after the space station we're talking
about probably 2025
it's when the
Space Station basically the life of the
space station will be but the next step
would be to go to Mars this is what
we're working on the suits and so on but
before we go to the Mars we have to
learn our lessons Mars is about a year
away from here and a year there and a
year back so you need to design systems
that are totally reliable for they will
last you know you don't have you can
repair them but you cannot exchange them
you cannot ask for help
so therefore the lunar surface is really
the place to go a to test and learn
about how we might live one day in Mars
and starting to live on the moon there
are many reasons to go the moon the moon
is really has a lot of oxygen believe it
or not contained in the soil a lot of
metals a lot of glass a lot of materials
that we can use both for construction of
vehicles on the moon or to make an
atmosphere to create propellant you know
oxygen is our propellant to go to Mars
so maybe it becomes a propellant depot
the challenges of the of the Moon
obviously is that you have a reduced
gravity so it's in many ways it helps
you but on the other hand when I was
working with Bucky fuller actually spend
time thinking about how we anchor these
things to the soil and the rock of the
moon the forces were so great so we
worked in a lot of different geometries
of how to make this inflatables and
inflatables are really the way to go we
have we're working right now on
inflatables and we're actually will fly
inflatables to the space station as
additional modules so it's really cool
the development of the new fabrics the
new materials that allow us to do this
so the vision now is actually to instead
of actually build a stationary base if
exploration is mobility I mean to
explore it means that you're gonna be
running around the moon and exploring
this mountains or or Mars and these
canyons and picking up samples so we're
looking at the potential and this is a
proposal that we're making to NASA to
actually explore the moon with these
Rovers this is an early Rover that pull
a program that it gave
a huge range of away from their module
but our proposal right now is to have
these vehicles two of these that would
take four astronauts each so you have a
crew of eight guys traveling on this
kind of Winnebago love of the moon you
know has that manipulator arm that can
actually pick things up and bring them
in and so we can experiment without
having to go out you could go out if you
need to and so this has an incredible
suspension system I'm not gonna bore you
with all the engineering but if you look
at this thing from the top it has all
the air and water and water tanks
so with this manipulator you can
actually exchange them as crews exchange
the the it's like taking a cruise you
know crews are going and cruise going
going out so it has the solar panels and
radiators and all these things and and
the interior basically is for
workstations where you live and work and
it has to house all of our needs you
know the hygiene the the you know you
name it he does food and so on the same
as the space station this these
scorpions actually have this nomadic
structure inflatable structure that
would expand and contract so when
they're camping and the two of them come
together they can mate and actually have
this tunnel this environment that will
serve as a workshop in a laboratory or a
place to play so this is really our now
the proposal the idea of actually
mobility on the moon and maybe that's
the way we should go to Mars so we're
using the Antarctic as an analogue right
now for some of these planetary missions
there's already bass and the Arctic and
some of this and the Antarctic I had the
pleasure and privilege to work in the
South Pole we won a competition a
national competition for the design of
the South Pole Station and it all you
know the reason I think we wanted is
because we're really thinking space
we're really thinking isolation we're
really thinking about extreme
environments people living in a very
dangerous environment it's really
strange when
you land there and the plane leaves you
know they can't turn the engines off
because the freezes it won't come on
again so you know you left there with
your bags and and this thing leaves so
you know what it where we learned really
is to design for the environments we're
looking at you know aerodynamics there's
the wind and the South Pole blows always
from the same place so this becomes like
a vehicle this is actually what it was
built but we use that as a as a great
analogue there's a lot of
experimentation going on there and then
I want to leave you with a last story
that is our own story that we serve
navigated the planet on our sailboat and
basically to teach children to teach
children about technology and
exploration and this is the route we
took we took basically went around the
world from Boston to the equator and
then just went around it as close as we
could to the tropical areas of the
planet we met really some fantastic
people we had a couple of projects that
we work with in terms of creating maps
we asked all the kids to make maps and
it was really wonderful for you graphic
designers because the maps who always
place themselves in the center of the
earth and in the front of it so we have
this fantastic collection of kids maps
where it was taking it's like a picture
of the earth taking from you know all
the different spots we were the other
one was oral history where we asked kids
the same to ask the same questions to
their friends their parents their
grandparents and people in their
community so and like what is the
technology that most influenced you you
know it was really beautiful to see the
differences just you know and the three
generations so we have a beautiful
collection of that so anyway we were
supported by NASA on this on this
project and we basically had this video
conference this
that we had in every place where we
could do it around the planet with high
schools local high schools then we
connected a high school in the United
States and many different states and
then an astronaut at NASA so we had a
three-way conversations and it was
really wonderful to to see the
conversations they were from you know
what jeans you wore to what music you
heard and in addition to all the science
and technology so it's a great trip we
survived so we're back we wanted to
leave you just with an one image again
from all of our exploring off planet
back to earth it always comes back to
the human condition and the human spirit
thank you for your attention thank you
[Applause]
[Music]